[Música]
a gente quer mudar o mundo mas não está
disposta a dar pra nós mesmos para isso
essa tarefa de mudar o mundo é muito
difícil para ser feito assim
aliás dessa forma qualquer tarefa é
grande demais
eu sai de onde estou respiro e volto
para onde eu quero estar
esse é o lema que eu queria para a minha
vida porque eu preciso estar presente
consciente e tudo o que eu faço
onde quer que eu vá eu sempre digo que é
tudo que a gente faz tem que vir de
dentro pra fora a mudança que eu quero
no mundo onde acontecem mintimir o medo
do olhar interior esconde nós mesmos os
monstros que habitam e impede que a
gente tem a oportunidade de crescer
autoestima fora da medida gera um
desequilíbrio assustador
a gente tem uma superioridade ilusória
muitas vezes ou mesmo as pessoas de alto
desempenho em a síndrome do impostor
gente boa mas que não sabe o seu real
valor
nos dois casos o que falta é o
autoconhecimento e esse autoconhecimento
só vem quando a gente entra em contato
com a gente mesmo
a gente entra em contato com nosso
interior contínuo olha pra dentro
a gente enxerga o nosso micro mundo
17 maio de 2002
sai bem cedo de casa e eu estava em
ribeirão preto na casa do irmão e morava
naquela época e minha mãe estava
viajando quando um descuido meu agente
sofreu um acidente de carro
o carro capotou
os 50 metros cinco vezes ea gente sofre
um acidente e pesado
a minha mãe não sofreu nada
incrivelmente mas eu acho que a cabeça
escoriações múltiplas e teve uma fratura
muito grave e quebrou o pescoço
literalmente o fator é a sétima vértebra
da coluna cervical e eu poderia ter
morrido ou até ficar tetraplégico
mas eu tô aqui pra contar pra vocês que
muitas vezes só entre em contato com seu
interior
se a gente passa por um momento de grave
crise
o meu contato começou na beira da
rodovia
no meio daquele caos todo e naquele
momento a vida me parou e me colocou de
frente com espelho que há tempos não
olhava e aquilo parecia um filme de
terror
foi assustador e precisei promoveu a
catarse naquele momento pra quem não
sabe catarse
é um processo de limpeza profunda e pra
limpar a gente precisa olhar se enxergar
estabelecer esse olhar interior
você tem muita disposição muitas vezes a
gente só promove esse olhar interior se
tem uma surpresa que a vida traz pra
gente
o que muita gente acha que o
autoconhecimento encontra nas bancas de
revistas nos livros de auto ajuda
os custos não percebe que mesmo depois
de ler uma infinidade de livros fazer
vários cursos continua sempre a mesma
ler não é aprender assim como se olhar
não é enxergar só se enxerga só se
entende que é acima de tudo estabelece a
auto responsabilidade de pesquisa do
brasil que diz que mais de 60 por cento
das pessoas estão insatisfeitas com as
atividades que exercem diariamente e
muitas delas apontam os culpados são os
outros né é o mercado é a empresa é a
vida é qualquer coisa é o destino
poucos entendem que o único responsável
pela punição que ele vive ali e agora
ele mesmo fala que existe uma diferença
muito grande entre aqueles que querem e
aqueles que precisam pois precisa
independente das condições o nosso
esforço acontece
e aí a gente vai ver uma coisa chamada
mágica da auto responsabilidade
tudo depende de mim todos os meus
caminhos
sou eu que faço tudo
após acidente estava no hospital e meio
deixou muito claro pra mim olha nós
fizemos o que tava com efeito e agora é
com você eu precisava tomar uma atitude
a minha vida naquele momento eu ganhava
e eu perdia tudo depende de mim sem
andar pelos corredores do hospital não
era fácil era muito difícil e doía muito
eu nem pensava um dia em voltar a correr
foram anos e anos de muita fisioterapia
e nem tudo foi fácil mas eu posso
garantir que tudo foi pouquíssimo todos
os esforços de todos os resultados que
eu gostei foram meus
o tempo passou e já com 35 anos
eu percebi que precisava mudar de novo
eu precisei novamente de ter coragem de
olhar para mim mesmo entender que aquele
luciano já não era mais suficiente para
aquela condição que eu tinha na minha
vida foi quando eu entendi que três
coisas eram muito importante para mim em
toda a minha vida correr fotografar e
ensinar
eu comecei a correr gente contra enviado
pelos médicos diziam que ela não pode
correr aí eu bem teimoso a única coisa
que eu quis fazer foi correr eu comecei
correndo cinco quilômetros né na verdade
nem foram cinco mas fique em 5 tons
quanto tempo exatamente nos 12
quilômetros em um determinado momento eu
cheguei nos 21
mas ali eu estacionei muito tempo
pequenos 21 porque eu pensava que eu não
dava conta de alencar
é ver a corrida como uma atividade
puramente esportiva é perguntar tem de
melhor
a corrida é um esporte com solitário por
natureza eu posso te chamar um colega
para correr comigo mas houve motivação é
minha
o diálogo interno é meu
sou eu que faço os meus caminhos e os
resultados são 100% meus quando eu corro
eu tenho tempo de prestar atenção em mim
olhar pro meu micromundo corrida
acima de tudo é a autogestão de todos os
nossos processos internos desde onde o
piso para onde eu vou
onde eu olho conta de água abrigo e o
mais importante o que eu penso enquanto
eu corro nada melhor do que fazer uma
maratona para descobrir isso eu mesmo
nunca quis
como já disse é para nos 21 e pensava
cara 42 nunca não é pra mim estava longe
achava grande né
e olha que eu já corri em 17 países
diferentes nas condições mais adversas
nunca foi avassalador na áfrica
no frio extremo do pólo norte
as provas longas de montanha no brasil e
na argentina nas quais eu fiquei mais de
cinco horas e meia em plena atividade
mas mesmo assim eu achava que aquilo não
era pra mim que uma maratona de rua 42
quilômetros
eu não conseguiria isso era eu me
sabotando e eu me transformando o
impostor e penso muito nos micro mundo
sabe
é muita gente quer mudar o mundo mudar a
comunidade da realidade das pessoas mais
inteiros mas esquece de olhar para si
mesmo
esquece ver temos tantas coisas boas em
nós mas também temos muitas coisas a
melhorar
não que as outras questões não sejam
importantes
mas a verdade é que não dou nada que não
tem como é que eu vou correr 42
quilômetros se eu simplesmente não
entendo como que eu cheguei até os 21
se não me enxergo como que eu vou ver o
outro
em abril de 2000 e 18 e minha irmã os
escrevendo na maratona de berlim land na
minha cabeça eu ia fazer até onde desce
que não tinha treinado pra fazer aquela
maratona e com ela não deu eu paro
só que na noite anterior à minha irmã
que tinha me convencido de que ela
machucou o pé e me ligou chorando olha
não vou poder correr mais eu fui agora
né
eu estava sozinho eu ia acompanhar agora
estava sozinho eu pensei tá batendo na
porta o desafio e eu disse para você vai
fazer
eu encarei o desafio dos 42 quilômetros
durante aquelas quatro horas e 27
minutos de plena atividade física
estabelece um novo contato comigo mesmo
eu estabeleci um novo contato com os
meus limites com as minhas barreiras e o
quebrei tudo o que vem todas as
barreiras e todos os meus limites e eu
parava a gente e eu abaixava e eu
gritava de dor
porque doía muito
eu chorei de dor foi muitas vezes e eu
penso muito e quando a gente tem essas
conquistas pessoais individuais de afeto
nosso micro mundo o nosso raio o nosso
entorno
cada vez que a gente tem uma conquista
dessa que supera em se aprimora e queria
combustível e potência pra todo mundo
está ao seu redor
o meu propósito como professor é de
aprimorar e eu tudo que eu faço na minha
vida em busca disso a proposta acima de
tudo tem a ver com o conhecer a ti mesmo
de entender quem você é e porque você
está aqui
se você responder quatro questões
básicas
talvez se consiga entender se a
propósito que é o que eu faço bem feito
que eu tenho prazer em fazer o mundo
precisa eo que eu recebi pra isso e
quando você descobriu que seu propósito
é você não é especial por isso você
precisa de mecanismos para colocar este
propósito eu em ação e no meu caso
parece bobagem ligar meu propósito com a
corrida em tese eu sou igual a todos os
corredores
eu não sou medalhista nunca vence uma
prova não faço a menor força pra ser
ninguém me paga pra correr
eu adoro correr e eu ia a não ser por
alguns seguidores nas redes sociais
ninguém se importa com as minhas
corridas ou seja o mundo não tá nem aí
pra isso mas no meu caso a corrida
inicialmente reconexão quando eu corro
eu corro pra ver o mundo
e depois eu volto a fotografar ele se
você ver uma foto minha você vai ver que
é muito mais que um clique
se você assistir uma aula minha você vai
ver que eu quero te levar sempre além
a minha visão é de se superar sempre se
aprimorar
como eu vou mudar a vida de alguém com
aquilo que ensina se eu simplesmente não
consigo me mudar
quem faz maratona aprendi que com
planejamento perseverança e trabalho se
faz qualquer coisa no seu dia a dia
assim como a fotografia fotografia
precisa de planejamento precisa de
perseverança e também precisa de
trabalho aplicar por clicar não resolve
nada
não conto a história e nada melhor que
uma boa história
vamos dar uma boa lição quando fotografo
com o meu olhar a serviço do mundo das
histórias que têm para contar que as
pessoas têm para contar ao longo desses
17 países que visitei
eu tento retratar o que o mundo tem para
ensinar as pessoas do meu micro mundo no
meu entorno
se eu coloco o espectador a pensar
diante de uma imagem
neste momento estou colocando meu
propósito em movimento
eu quero deixar bem claro que primeiro
eu fotografo pra mim porque encontra na
minha fotografia beleza que eu busco pra
minha vida
só depois que a fotografia me transforma
é que eu posso tentar transformar outras
cidades com aquilo que eu faço
correr fotografar e ensinar
parece tudo separado mas na minha vida e
tudo junto é com isso que eu gosto
transformar os meus micro - eu tenho
intercessão que encontro com cada um
cada dia sai de onde estou
respiro e volto para onde eu quero estar
correndo fotografando e ensinando as
pessoas a se aprimorar e vocês vão ver
cada um de vocês é possível você
transformar o seu micro mundo a partir
de você e quando isso acontecer vai ser
maravilhoso mas não faça isso sozinho
porque não existe fotos em fotógrafo
vezes corridas em corredor que não
existe professor sem aluno saiu de onde
estou
respiro e volta pra onde eu quero estar
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]
[Música]